digamos que tenemos un ácido binario hx
en donde x es una halógeno que puede ser
flúor cloro y bromo o yodo si hx zona
este protón nos quedamos con la base
conjugada x menos en el vídeo anterior
vimos que entre más estable sea la base
conjugada es más probable que hx donde
su protón entonces más fuerte es el
ácido echemos un vistazo a estos cuatro
ácidos binarios tenemos el ácido
fluorhídrico con un pk
de aproximadamente 3 positivo ácido
clorhídrico con una beca
de aproximadamente menos 7 ácido brom
hídrico de menos 9 y ácido cítrico de
menos 10
sabemos que entre menor sea el valor de
peca más fuerte es el ácido así que a
medida que bajamos el valor de pecar
disminuye y por lo tanto la fuerza del
ácido aumenta aumenta la acidez entonces
podemos decir que el ácido clorhídrico
es el ácido más fuerte de estos cuatro
porque tiene el valor más chico de pecar
entonces su base conjugada debe ser la
más estable la base conjugada del ácido
yo hídrico es el guión yoduro y menos y
aquí tenemos las diferentes bases con
jugadas
tenemos el ión fluoruro que es la base
conjugada de hf el lyon cloruro que es
la base conjugada de hcl también tiene
el hombro muro que es la base con jugada
de hbr y por supuesto tenemos a lyon
yoduro que como dijimos antes es la base
con jugada de h y el ión yoduro es el
más estable porque h
es el ácido más fuerte y podemos
explicar la estabilidad de la base con
jugada en términos del tamaño del guión
recuerden que conforme nos movemos hacia
abajo en un grupo de la tabla periódica
aumenta el tamaño del unión aumenta el
tamaño del unión y esto como ayuda a la
estabilidad de la base con jugada bueno
necesitamos pensar en esta carga
negativa tenemos una carga negativa en
el guión yoduro que se mueve en un gran
espacio lo que hace que este año sea más
estable recuerden que los electrones
se repelen entre sí pero si tenemos un
gran espacio en el que se puedan
extender entonces podemos estabilizar
esa carga negativa este es más estable
que por ejemplo el ión fluoruro en donde
el ión fluoruro tiene una carga negativa
que está concentrada en un espacio
pequeño lo que desestabiliza este año a
comparación de la unión yoduro de
lannion yoduro es más estable y por lo
tanto es más fácil que el h y donde un
protón el h y es el ácido más fuerte
observen que esto es diferente al vídeo
anterior en donde hablamos sobre electro
negatividad y comparamos elementos del
mismo período en la tabla periódica es
decir nos movimos horizontalmente
dijimos que el año fluoruro era el más
estable porque el flúor es el
más electro negativo y por lo tanto
puede estabilizar mejor una carga
negativa pero conforme nos movemos hacia
abajo en el grupo de la tabla periódica
la electro negatividad disminuye esa
puede ser la tendencia dominante porque
si la electro negatividad disminuye
conforme bajamos esto nos predice que h
efe sería el ácido más fuerte pero eso
no es lo que observamos así que conforme
nos movemos hacia abajo en un grupo de
la tabla periódica es el tamaño de la
unión lo que determina la estabilidad de
la base conjugado entonces entre más
grande sea el a nyon es más fácil
estabilizar la carga negativa y por lo
tanto más estable es la base conjugada
entre más estable sea la base conjugada
es más fácil que h x donde un protón y
por lo tanto
más fuerte es el ácido otra cosa muy
importante en la que podemos pensar es
en la fuerza del enlace ya dijimos que
el ácido hídrico es nuestro ha sido más
fuerte con el valor más bajo ppk a este
enlace justo aquí debe de ser el más
fácil de romper y si es más fácil de
romper entonces es más fácil donar este
protón y podemos tener una idea de la
fuerza de enlace de nuestros ácidos
observando la energía de disociación de
enlace que también se le puede llamar
entalpía de enlace recuerden la energía
de disociación de enlace mide la
cantidad de energía que necesitamos para
romper un enlace en estado gaseoso si
observamos nuestros saludos de hidrógeno
y pensamos en los enlaces observen lo
que sucede con la energía de enlace
es más difícil romper este enlace entre
el hidrógeno y el flúor se necesita más
energía y conforme bajamos podemos ver
que la energía disminuye así que sólo
necesitamos 299 kilos por mol para
romper este enlace entre h y estos son
valores aproximados de la energía de
disociación si el enlace h
es más fácil de romper eso significa que
cuando pensamos en el ácido será más
fácil que donde un protón y por lo tanto
tiene el valor más pequeño de pk y el
ácido clorhídrico es el ácido más fuerte
entre estos cuatro ácidos binarios